a vote is scheduled in Washington today
on a government rule change that could
affect how you use your favorite
websites Obama era rules on net
neutrality stopped providers like AT&T
and Verizon from playing favorites and
charging more for faster access Julianna
Goldman is outside the FCC in Washington
which will likely vote today Julianna
good morning good morning more than a
recent survey found that more than 80%
of Americans support net neutrality
rules now protestors have been gathering
here ahead of today's vote someone a
delay others want Congress to intervene
but no matter they say that their fight
is not over net neutrality has long been
a hot-button issue but with its repeal
now all but certain supporters from
celebrities like Alyssa Milano Cher and
Mark Ruffalo - tech companies like
Twitter Netflix and Vimeo are up in arms
high quality streaming for companies
that can afford it they're arguing that
the freedom of the Internet is at stake
the Obama era rules prevent internet
service providers like AT&T and Verizon
from treating websites differently and
charging more money to reach their
customers online you can say what you
want Pennsylvania Attorney General Josh
Shapiro wants to keep the rules in place
without it then big companies can decide
what content you're gonna get at a
certain speed and what content you're
gonna get say at a slower speed
he and 17 other attorneys general have
asked the FCC to delay the vote in part
because they say the comment period was
hijacked by millions of fake submissions
using names of real people they stole
their voice in our American democracy
and I'm not going to stand for that FCC
Chairman Ajit PI who was appointed by
President Trump says the criticism is
overblown since he announced the new
plan last month he says he and his wife
have received threatening calls even
ethnic slurs on Twitter these comments
sir getting rid of the government
authority over the internet is the exact
opposite of authoritarianism hi who was
appointed by President Trump has said
that net neutrality allows the federal
government to micromanage the Internet
he says it stifles innovation now later
now the FCC has five commissioners who
will all be leading today and all three
Republicans support repealing these
rules
John Julianna thanks